[Music]
all right we're moving on to what's
driving you crazy got some real signs of
progress around the 95 in the northern
215 beltway come on along
we're
still polling one
small part of that massive project we've
been talking about
well it's coming to life the multi-use
trail from words on a map
to the 3d animation of walkers
bicyclists and even a jogger
eight news now digital data reporter
greg haas
has found the early stages of the real
thing
this six seven hundred foot bridge will
be dedicated to pedestrians and bikes
join up with an area where it adjoins
with the road
yeah so eventually that trail will
connect grand montecito on the west to
tanea on the east it's just going to be
part
of several miles of new bike lanes and
sidewalks we've got links to this and
all of our centennial blow stories on
our website eight news now dot com
click traffic then driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone
if there's something driving you crazy
the email address traffic eight
at eight news now dot com